I am Nicholas be with Matt Welch it's
asked a libertarian 2012 we're
celebrating the paperback publication at
the end of the month of the Declaration
of Independence this question comes from
open spirit via YouTube four years ago
you guys declared that the libertarian
moment was upon us in this country was
poised to enter a new age of freedom
how'd that go was it at night because I
think I slept through man I think it's
the best question so far you're right we
wrote those words right basically as
tarp was being passed and you can look
at the world since then and say we've
gone through kind of a big government
[ __ ] show that's all true at the same
time there's been a genuine populists
backlash against big government I think
the American attitudes on the public
opinion level on all sorts of things
whether it's against bailout economics
whether it's for the legalization of
marijuana where there's now an open
majority of Americans who think that we
should be legalizing marijuana to
approval of gay marriage and other kind
of tolerance issues they have been
spiking since that moment for years ago
politics is lagging indicator which we
talk about in the book so we're only
beginning to see some of this work its
way through the political process but
right now I think that we are much more
libertarian as a country it's just that
the policies are less libertarian yeah
the politics as a lagging indicator is a
central tenet of the book and I think
it's true we are having a discussion
about libertarian ideas within the
Republican Party that was not going on
five years ago which is good even people
like Jim DeMint hardcore social con
saying he can talk about legalizing
drugs and dropping defense spending as
long as it's in the service of
minimizing government we're getting
there it's going to take a lot longer
than we thought and hopefully you know
when you wake up open secret you'll you
know you'll see that we're getting more
libertarian Matt Welsh Nicholas be asked
a libertarian 2012 keep em comin
you